Recently,
I've been declaring
to anyone who would listen
that I am a dangerous woman.
(Applause)
Now, declaring that boldly like this
still feels a bit dangerous,
but it also feels right.
At this time in my life,
about to be 77,
I have --
(Applause)
I love when you're applauded
for your age --
(Laughter)
but I'll take it.
(Applause)
About to be 77, I realize
that I have nothing left to prove,
less to lose,
and I'm more impatient about everything.
The true, slow pace towards equality,
the rise in sexism, racism,
violence against women and girls ...
And I'm angry, too,
at the climate deniers
who are stealing the future
from our children and grandchildren.
Friends, we are living in dangerous times.
And such times call for all of us
to be more dangerous.
Now, what do I mean by this?
I don't mean being feared.
It's not that kind of dangerous.
But I do mean being more fearless.
I mean speaking the truth
when silence is a lot safer.
I mean speaking up in rooms
for those who aren't present,
especially those rooms
where decisions are made
about our lives and our bodies.
We need to be in those rooms,
showing up for one another,
challenging the cultural construct
that encourages us,
especially women and girls,
to compete, compare,
criticize.
We have to end this.
And speaking out
against the policies and the politics
that divide us and diminish
our collective power
as a global community of women,
and the men and the allies
who stand with us.
Becoming dangerous also means
embracing whatever risks are necessary
to create a world
where women and girls are safe
in their homes and at work,
where all voices are represented
and respected,
all votes counted,
the planet protected.
And this is all possible.
Because we're ready for this.
We're better prepared
than any generation ever before us,
better resourced, better connected.
In many parts of the world,
we're living longer than ever.
Women over 65 are among
the fastest-growing populations on earth,
with the potential for becoming
the most powerful, too.
Now --
(Applause)
What a change this represents.
Postmenopausal women like me,
not that long ago,
were considered useless
or crazy.
We were valued for caregiving
and grandmothering --
and I really love that part.
But we were pushed aside
and expected to retire
to our rocking chairs.
Women on the dangerous side of 60
are not retiring.
We are rewiring --
(Applause)
taking all that we know and have done --
and that is a lot --
to redefine what age looks like,
can do, can accomplish.
But becoming dangerous isn't about
becoming a certain age,
because at each end of the age spectrum,
brave women and girls are stepping up,
taking the risk to create change.
I became a risk-taker
early in my life's journey.
I had to,
or have my life defined by the limitations
for a girl growing up in the rural South,
with no money, no connections,
no influence.
But what wasn't limited
was my curiosity about the world
beyond my small town,
beyond the small minds
of a still-segregated South,
a world that I glimpsed in the newsreels
at the one movie theater in town,
and a world that got a lot closer to me
when I met Miss Shirley Rountree,
my eighth-grade English teacher.
From the minute she walked
into the classroom,
her high heels clicking,
she was a woman in charge,
with perfect hair, signature red lips,
colorfully coordinated, head to toe.
I wanted to be her.
Gratefully, she became my first mentor
and helped me become me.
With her support, I got
a scholarship to college --
the first in my family --
and landed at a big state university,
right in the middle of two
great social justice movements:
civil rights for African Americans
and equal rights for women.
I joined both with enthusiasm,
only to discover that my newfound activism
and my fermenting feminism
would often be in direct conflict
with my deeply embedded need to please
and be popular.
In my first job as a college teacher,
I broke the rules,
and I encouraged students
to join me in the protest marches.
And when I found out
that my male colleague
with the same experience and education
was being paid more than me,
I mounted a personal protest.
When my raise was denied,
with the excuse that
he had a family to support,
so did I as a single mom.
But I dropped my protest to keep my job.
Today, millions of women
are making this compromise,
staying in their jobs without equal pay
for equal work.
And as one of the first women
on television in the '70s,
I was warned that focusing
on women's stories
would limit my career opportunities,
and maybe it did.
But I got to produce and host
breakthrough programming for women,
while at the same time,
remaining silent
about sexual harassment
and listening to consultants
who were hired to advise me
about my appearance.
"Become a blonde."
I did.
"Lower your voice."
I tried.
"Lower your necklines."
I didn't.
(Laughter)
But I did wear those ugly anchor suits
with those scarves that look
something like men's ties.
And later, in the power
positions in media,
often as the first or only woman,
aware of being judged
through that gender lens,
I struggled from time to time
to find the right balance between
being a leader for women
and not being entirely defined
as a woman leader.
But today, I'm proud to be known
(Applause)
As an activist, advocate, feminist
and as a newly declared dangerous woman,
I'm caring less what others say
and saying more clearly
what I think and feel.
And let me be clear:
I acknowledge my privilege
in being able to do that,
to speak my truth.
And to stand here today
with this opportunity
to talk to you about women and power --
note I did not say "empowered."
I don't think we're waiting
to be empowered.
I think we have power.
(Applause)
What we need are more opportunities
to claim it, to use it,
to share it.
And yes, I know --
there are women with power
who don't use it well or wisely
and who don't share it.
I've heard, as I'm sure you have,
those stories that begin with,
"The worst boss I ever had
was a woman ... "
And we could all name women leaders
who have not made us proud.
But we can change all of that
with a simple but brilliant idea
that I first heard from a risk-taking,
dangerous congresswoman from New York
named Bella Abzug.
Bella said, "In the 21st century,
women will change the nature of power
rather than power changing
the nature of women."
From the moment I heard that --
(Applause)
I thought, "This is our call to action.
This is our biggest opportunity."
And as a journalist and an activist,
I've seen this idea in action,
documenting the stories of women
on both sides in long-term conflicts,
coming together
and defying the official power
to form alliances and find their own ways
to ending violence in their communities.
And as an activist,
I've traveled to places
where it's dangerous to be born a woman,
like eastern Congo,
where a war is being waged
on the bodies of women.
There, at a healing and leadership
center called City of Joy,
brave Congolese women
are transforming pain into power
by training survivors of sexual assault
to return to their villages as leaders.
And at recent climate summits,
I've observed women climate leaders
working behinds the scenes,
out of the public spotlight,
making sure that the negotiations
toward global climate agreement
continue to move forward.
So as we move forward
in our lives and work
and we have more power and influence,
let's change the nature of power
by dismantling some of the barriers
that remain for those who follow
by advocating and agitating
for fairer and truer
and more equal representation
in every room and at every table.
Now, be warned:
if you advocate for a woman
for an open position or promotion,
you could be challenged with,
"You're playing the women's card"
or "the race card"
if advocating for a woman of color.
I've had this experience,
as I'm sure you have.
"Are you running an affirmative
action program here at PBS?"
asked one of my board members
when, as a new president,
I announced my first hires
as five qualified women.
Now, my affirmative action had been
to ask that the search firm
bring me a candidate list
that included the names of women
and people of color
who just happened to be, in my judgment,
the best candidates
for the position as well.
I say, dangerous women
and our allies:
it's time to play the women's card,
play the race card,
play all our cards.
(Applause)
Not to win the power game,
but to lead to better outcomes
for everyone.
And it's time, too,
to discard that scarcity theory,
the one that says,
there's only room
for one of us at the top,
so protect your turf,
don't make friends or allies.
Changing the nature of power
transforms "protect your turf"
into "share your turf,"
it encourages coalitions,
it builds alliances,
it strengthens and sustains friendships.
My women friends
are my source of renewable energy.
(Applause)
So are my mentors, my champions,
my supporters, my sponsors,
and all of the ways that we can
and do show up for each other.
We can become our sources
of renewable power
for each other.
And along the way,
we need to take better care of ourselves,
and here, I am not the best role model.
I don't meditate.
I don't exercise regularly.
But I do live aerobically.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Because I believe we can't be dangerous
from the sidelines,
and there's just too much to be done.
So let's use all our power.
How about the power of money?
Let's allocate more
of our philanthropic dollars,
our campaign donations,
our investment funds,
to increase economic and political equity.
And let's leverage the power
of media and technology
that we have
in our hands, quite literally,
to elevate each other's stories and ideas;
to practice civility;
to seek the truth,
which is diminishing
and is threatening
free and open societies.
Yes, we have all that we need
to move our communities forward.
And the best thing we have,
and what we must remember,
is to be there for each other.
We will move forward together,
willing now to take more risk,
to be more fearless,
to speak up, speak out
and show up
for one another.
George Bernard Shaw once wrote
that he believed in his opinion
that his life belonged to the community,
that the harder he worked,
the more he lived
and that he wanted to be
thoroughly used up when he died.
He went on to write,
"Life is no brief candle to me
but a splendid torch
that I have got hold of for a moment
before passing to future generations."
I, too, do not view my life
as a brief candle,
although I am burning it at both ends.
(Laughter)
And I do want it, and me,
to be thoroughly used up when I die.
But at this point in my life's journey,
I am not passing my torch.
I am holding it higher than ever,
boldly, brilliantly,
inviting you to join me
in its dangerous light.
Thank you.
(Applause)